chapter one litter of blood this is the
opposite of what I want to be doing
right now I'm kind of sick at the lemon
I'm going to Japan next week the idea of
being in a club sounds terrible Wow we
just killed this man why ah multiple men
hell gasp Patrol oh just stuff why are
you by writing all of a sudden this is
still a cutscene yes I'm gonna be one of
those foreigners next week don't wait
also every video game villain is an
angry old man who sits in a large tower
if any of you played DMC like the most
recent one that's exactly what that is
Oh gameplay oh my god oh I got to pull
my tee down for this oh I'm here to pay
my respects press f to pay respects I
know if you guys are aware but uh Deadly
Premonition is my favorite video game
and I'm already getting Deadly
Premonition vibes which means I'm for it
I have to [ __ ] him he's a cutscene again
I could have said no I guess he's gonna
show me the same thing I just want to
play the video game Wow
how many dead people have we seen so far
it's gotta be like four or five my god
no no no gameplay Oh combat question
mark how am I gonna whoa okay alright
well they all have guns why aren't you
shooting me you idiots hey Bros come at
me
I'm doing it who'll evade ooh ooh look
at me go I did kick a bunch of boys in
the crotch until they died even though
they all had guns we don't question it
it would have made more sense even as a
[ __ ] even from a tutorial perspective if
only one of them had a gun so it didn't
just seem like they ran and we all drop
their guns but what do I know I'm not a
game developer so well why do we want to
make a truce with them now and they just
[ __ ] did that they seemed like a
bunch of dicks and I there were
assassins and they all showed up with
guns I did not have a gun still managed
to take all of them to death
okay what's up food hello yes I will eat
no okay yes do I have money right now oh
dude I got thirty thousand yen what's
white soda that's expensive boost your
attack let's do it okay things are
finally happening this actually looks
pretty good for how dense it is what is
this y'all go video games this is an
arcade I don't know I can't see anything
to interact with nothing well listen
icon man why would you why would you
play me like that I think this might be
a strip club let's find out
yeah all right sexy club time remember
how I was talking about how the streams
family-friendly but I guess I'm not
allowed to stay here well I mean it's
nice I guess someone's naughty
apparently it's pretty on-brand for me
the first thing I do is go to a strip
club on my 18th birthday I went to a
strip club was my idea I was like yeah
let's go to a strip club and then I went
and I was horrified I never went back to
one ever again since I wish you would
just sit oh wow people bitching about
being single this really is a good
simulator would someone mentioned ramen
hold up is this gonna be noodles stir
this way I'm trying to find her ah man
man I'm trying new but it's making me
engage in conversation I just want
noodles damn dude it's pretty up yes
yeah I'm like actually legitimately
impressed with this combat just a lot
more detail than it needs to be look how
far I kicked him one of my Batman
amazing game of the year I see you want
me to crap one of these and then stash
it yeah we go okay now can I can I knock
him out what but this it's doing this
itself that made me really uncomfortable
was like my game was possessed don't
control my inventory for me all right I
don't care I just want noodles is this
noodles yeah
no but look at all this stuff damn well
yeah someone that's noodles I want ramen
but I can't read Japanese yes hello
excuse me excuse me I will take food
please yes I don't know what's so that
is look how good these pictures are are
these real well let's go with that I
wanted noodles man doing it no no no I
want it I want it order I'm gonna fight
more people here is that what's
happening oh heck ah harassment oh heck
she got assaulted it's not even
harassment witness he hit her oh I tried
supercharged name what am I [ __ ] Goku
okay dude this combat stuff I imagine
it's actually pretty challenging to like
obviously I'm not trying very hard I
could pull my pull that out there we go
but I feel like when you get further in
the game it's probably pretty difficult
you have to dodge a bunch I just really
like the way it looks
animated nicely well flames come out
where you at boy oh yes the harasser
himself Toyota oh yes fights heroes
Hey
like the dramatic intro the grab is cool
- that's great
that is so satisfying and then I'm gonna
grab this bike hit you with it oh the
other dude did it to me are you serious
brah pseudo is here I love your video
games sir big fan of your work I'm sorry
about that pseudo please keep making
video games how much money that is but
oh these guys aren't even thugs that
town punks I actually probably should
have eaten before coming here because I
don't have a lot of yeah you can't this
you just can't reorient it very easily
well I want to grab a chair damn it dude
I'm just trying to pick it just trying
to pick an item up yes hit him oh very
good boss fight okay okay
how does gone go see okay he's one of
him so I should it should be wait here
we go it should be way easier for me to
like dodge and stuff and I think I can
eat my food if I need to okay
god this games cool how do i equipment
no inventory white soda let's take it
because I think it ups my attack hey bud
Oh I was walking I didn't know you could
do that alright but why am i fighting
him I punched him and then he was mad at
me and now I'm fighting him
whatever it's fine alright that's
probably his law helpful unless he has
another one oh really got me that dude
and then you floated ah Japanese Jesus
and it's awesome style okay get your
opponents help lower than wait for the
prompt to rapidly press square alright
is that now
just thank you
big fan that was supposed to be
finishing me oh good
yes ah combat cinematics sorry your
life's been [ __ ] doji did did you boo
Japanese Jesus wait I'm Japanese Jesus
remember which one of us is no it was
him
chapter 2 Oh